[Music]
so you didn't answer that question you
you you went on and you gave me a
Hebrews um Hebrews 1 verse3 which is not
Jesus Christ himself saying this well
that's not the question you asked to me
respectfully host you
ask wait let me ask what was the
question let me ask Brighton what what
was the question you didn't ask the same
question to Brighton that you asked to
me that's the point no listen listen
Brighton was answering the question and
you came in and you said no that's not
how it is you said the father is not the
same as the son okay I yeah I said the
father I said Jesus is not the father
that's what I said because that's what
Brighton so I I clarifi that Jud you
said hose 11 verse what but you but
you're you're still not acknowledging
the verse that I gave you because you
asked for me a verse and I gave it to
you are you able to acknowledge that the
say that Jesus has the same God logic
God logic if we are going to accept all
the Bible okay if we are going to accept
everything in the Bible I can give you
Bible verses which you will never
believe is that like you will never
accept so H I'm asking you
is is everything in the Bible um like
the word of God uh the parts that are
the word of God where it's God speaking
thus says the Lord of course I believe
all of it is inspired by God um but that
that's not you're changing the subject
here you asked me where in the Bible
does it say that Jesus has is has the
same being as the father and I gave you
Hebrews 1:3 I know that you don't
believe in the Bible
okay but you all I'm asking you to do is
just acknowledge what
it me listen listen the reason why I ask
this question is that because can you
just listen to me I know I know Paul I
know Paul Paul even said that Jesus
Christ is God and he took he took on
human flesh and he came on this head and
others so I know about all those things
you understand that is why I didn't ask
about those people because I know what
they they are capable of you understand
so I as you about Jesus Christ himself
no you didn't you asked me this is
exactly what you said my brother you
said show me a Bible verse that says
Jesus has the same being as the father
that's what you said to me you didn't
say show me where Jesus himself says
that he has the same being as the father
which I can show you these things but
that's not what you asked okay which
wait wait for me um um someone said I
should open umos for him um Juda said I
should open hose let me read after that
but you're moving on to something else
now no he said I should open Hosea for
him I will come to that yeah but it's
not related to this you're just going to
change the subject again that's what I'm
saying I'm not going to change the
subject all right so you're going to
read you're going to read Hosea 119 and
then you're going to come back to
Hebrews
1:3 I will not carry out my my Fierce
anger nor will I devastate Ephraim again
for I am God and not a man the the Holy
One among you I will not come against
their
cities all right beautiful verse
so
um so I know that you
don't so so I know that you don't
believe in the Bible just like I don't
believe in the Quran right but I can
acknowledge what the Quran says like for
example I know that the Quran says that
Muhammad is the Seal of the prophets I
don't believe that but I know the Quran
says that I can't be honest and say it
doesn't say that you know what I'm
saying I I know I know you don't believe
I know you don't believe okay I know you
don't believe in I know you don't
believe I only drew that I only use that
as an example of being able to
acknowledge a text even though you don't
believe it so I'm asking you can you
acknowledge
that says that
I'm just asking can you acknowledge that
Hebrews 1:3 does say that Jesus has the
same being as the father can you just
acknowledge that okay so uh before
before I acknowledge I have to ask you
some question if you agree come on okay
no because I have to ask you some
question concerning your your your Bible
right I have to ask you question conning
your Bible you don't have to ask me
another question just I have to ask you
because okay okay your Bible said God is
not a man nor a son of man and your
Bible said again your Bible will let me
know that God became a man so how do you
expect me to should I believe in God
being a man
or God is not a man my my my my brother
and my host I I would gladly address
your question just respectfully after
you have answered the one I've been
asking for the past 3 minutes now I have
no problem addressing what you just said
it's a good question it's a fair
question but please can you just
acknowledge Hebrews 1:3 first and then
we can move on to your question is that
fair okay go on so all I'm asking is
that can you acknowledge that Hebrews
1:3 says that excuse me one second
brother that Hebrews 1:3 because we we
read it already that Hebrews 1:3 says
that the son has the same being as the
father right we both saw that right and
I'm telling what what I'm telling you
you don't you don't understand me what
I'm telling you you don't understand me
I'm asking you like no no brother wait
wait wait wait the question should be
who is saying the words who is saying
these words that is that is what that's
why he he he don't want to agree okay
that's why he don't want to
agree I think there's a I don't know if
there's a Miss there's like a missing
link here the reason why Hebrews 1:3 fit
your question or your challenge was
because you didn't say show me where
Jesus himself out of his own mouth says
that he has the same being as the father
what you asked me was give me a Bible
verse that says Jesus has the same being
as the father so I gave it to you
Hebrews 13 listen that is the question
you know that is a question I asked
Brighton before you came that's the
question ask that cuz he never said that
no okay that's the that's the question I
was tackling with Brighton okay so it
wasn't you no Brighton wasn't saying the
same thing I was saying I came up and
corrected Brighton Brighton said you
came out you came out and you Brighton
was saying that God is the same like the
father is the same as Jesus Christ right
no no that's not what he said Jesus the
father is the same as the son right said
the father he said the father is the son
that's
yes so and you came up and you you
corrected him and you said no the father
is not the son right correct after that
I ask you that uh after that you make
you make your point and I ask you that
can you find me in your Bible where it
says okay because according to I'm
talking According To Jesus Christ where
he says
that so um how do you understand the
question yeah so I said I to I to expl
the distinction between the father and
the son and I repeat it how they are
they have the same nature the same
nature right but they are distinct
persons you said show me a Bible verse
where it says that the son is the has
the same nature as the father I said
sure here's Hebrew okay before before
then before then I knew I knew there are
so many Bible vers even Paul says Paul
said okay I knew about that that one but
question I wanted to ask you is that
Jesus himself because I know about the
Bible vers even about Paul so I know and
I don't believe in those people that's
why I want you you don't believe in
Jesus either I don't believe in Paul I
don't believe in Paul I don't Jesus
either you said what you don't you don't
if I show you Jesus's words you're not
going to believe those either okay show
me show me where Jesus himself said said
that before that so you do acknowledge
that Hebrews 1:3 says that Jesus has the
same nature as the father you just don't
you just reject that because those
aren't Jesus's own words is that correct
okay wait wait my friend that's what
he's saying you are just making it too
long just from I'm I'm just trying to
get I'm just I don't know why I don't
know why I don't know why he can't cope
with what I'm saying I said quote from
Jesus word to me brother because you're
change because you're changing your your
goalpost your at first your goalpost was
a Bible verse now that I gave you the
Bible verse now the goost shift to no
where does Jesus himself say this you
see you see what I'm saying listen
listen now now it's a rephrasing now let
him rephrase now rephrase the question I
have no problem guys please it's getting
too getting anywhere I have no problem
with his rephrasing I what I have a
problem with is him not admitting what
the text says before moving on that's my
problem okay the reason why okay maybe
maybe maybe because the reason why I I
like I I don't sorry in this context the
question the question is not being
answered because it's should be um um um
an equivocal equivocal um statement from
Jesus not from somebody else else
question see if that was brother if that
was the question you would have a point
but that wasn't the question the
question was give me a Bible verse that
says Jesus is the same nature as the
father so I said
okay now address the question address
the question question after I'll address
the question after I get the
acknowledgement of the first
question that no that wasn't the
question I was asking so how host host
host wild host the answer the answer to
that that point why where he's asking
because he want us to confirm that that
that verse says that that verse says
that but that is what not what we meant
meant what is meant is is an equivocal
statement from
Jesus that's what I that is the point
you okay so now let me ask you this okay
now let me ask you this so now that we
got answer the question answer the
question question on top of a question
please let me let me deal with you let
me deal with you because if that's going
to be your standard of questioning then
you're going to fall into some trouble
if Jesus himself doesn't say the words
me and the I and the father have the
same nature although I can show you this
but I am the father of the same nature
if he doesn't say that explicitly does
that mean that it's not
true that it's not
scriptural brother for me for me as an
individual for me wait host sorry host
give me give me one minute please to
respond to him for me as an individual
when you say when you when you extending
the word of God and you come to me and
you want me to believe because God's
word should be listened to
I should take that seriously so I should
po questions that are very very relevant
you know so in those questions I will
ask you what you I what when you say God
came on Earth to save us I will have
certain questions to ask you understand
my
brother you didn't answer my question
I'm coming to I'm coming to it I'm
coming to it I'm just extending for you
to know my
ground brother I know your ground I
don't have a problem with your position
I'm just asking to answer the question
please if you
can what is your question say again okay
if Jesus does not say in the exact words
I and the father have the same God right
if he doesn't say that out of his own
mouth in those words does that mean that
it's not scripturally
true no it it might cause cast cast a
doubt in my mind because this is a very
very uh fundamental issue
you know he has to when he is God he
comes on Earth this is this is something
very important if it is true so he has
to make me understand or make me know
because he came for that purpose to talk
to save Humanity you know is very
important when you say wait let me just
answer your let me just answer you
please I'm just waiting on that then
okay okay when he is God he comes on
Earth he lefts certain points blank like
that and left certain individuals who
are who are not carrying a very good
reputation in Society come to me and
talk to me after all I know their
background or their dealings I will not
take itly because it goes it has to do
with my salvation so this Jesus when he
comes when he is God he has to show
certain certain things like characters
of God the nature of God not dying not
dying because God Never Dies not knowing
something God knows everything you
understand I answer your question how
can he come and not so certain nature
that what was my question what was my
question is shouldn't if Jesus shouldn't
show that he has the same nature as God
or characters of God something like that
if he doesn't show that in in scripture
does it mean that the scripture is not
right and your answer is my answer is no
I will have a doubt on it who says it so
so so just
I got you I got you so just to be clear
wait so just to be clear let me let me
let me say this so just so just to be
clear Jesus doesn't have to say out of
his own mouth I have the same nature as
the father for it to be true so but me
showing you in the scripture that it
says that but then his character no wait
wait his character his his being the way
he he himself his being his Essence
should show those characters of God but
is not sh that even physically
spiritually is not I didn't understand I
didn't understand what you're saying
what I'm saying is when he came the the
the the God's Essence the essence of God
we should have seen that in him even if
he doesn't say yeah I I can show you
yeah very good see that's beautiful I
like
that ver vers
wait after after that after that after
that you have to answer the that
question before you before you you can
move to another question I love what
versatile said he said even
iFit I asked you the question but you've
never answered me you want to move to no
I did answer you now you're changing
your question no I said from Jesus I
said from Jes Jesus answer me before you
move if you can't answer me just tell me
you can answer me so that we move to
different one I think that you should
say that hey I I you answered my first
question but I want to said my question
because when you came I was talking
point to Jesus I said I want from Jesus
Jesus MTH himself you didn't say that to
me brother can you be honest and say and
admit you didn't say that to me so can I
ask a question now pleas wait wait
before before that let's get the let's
get the host to admit something here
host can you
admit can you admit that you did not ask
me out of Jesus's words can you admit
you didn't say that to me okay maybe
okay I said I said the question I was
trying to ask that is I I want I want
from Jesus MTH himself because I said I
I told you that I already know about
what I understand you you don't have to
repeat it you don't have to repeat
yourself I know what you're saying I
know about what Paul Paul said about
Jesus Christ and other said about Jesus
Christ I ask me specifically about Jesus
I don't believe in that because I before
I will believe I want from that doesn't
matter that does matter if you believe
it or not you didn't ask me hey God
logic show me out of Jesus's words where
he says he has the same nature as the
father you only asked me for a Bible
verse now hold on please let me let me
this please if I can finish please let
me just finish this just 30 seconds when
you say can you show me a Bible verse
where it says Jesus has the same nature
as the father that's not the same
question as show me where Jesus himself
out of his own mouth says that he has
the same nature as the father so you
didn't ask me that you asked me for a
Bible
ver wait
please hold on a second so now you're
changing the question to show me out of
Jesus's own words you get it and I have
no problem dealing with that but you
need to acknowledge that you didn't ask
me that at first you can't answer the
question I think just you're changing
your question I answered your first one
and because want to accept that you want
to change your question is it big deal
for you to answer the question hello yes
okay I want to ask a question pleas so
ver said something very important
onic ver said something important that I
liked he said that we should see God
logic can you answer the question you
got you got to stop it like you got to
have like
discussion if you can't answer the
question then then you tell me you can't
answer
theost wait wait wait he want to get
somewhere he want to get somewhere with
me I don't know I I'm curious to know
what he's uh bringing for
about know the reason why I don't don't
because he knows he knows definitely
that he cannot
get he cannot get that so he's making
the topic long on that that making it
look like you know
you any anyse in the Bible
please please let it be one by one one
by one one after the other one after the
other two three of you should not be
talking at the same time please thank
you thank you you hold on a bit I second
one second I want to ask a question
please please on you're cutting into the
conversation right now God logic uh yeah
so I don't I don't think you hear
yourself you're cutting into the
conversation let me no no I I want the
same same top you have to wait my friend
so please please I want to ask you this
question wait please please wait let him
address the first question please let
him address the first question yeah so
so versatile you said very beautifully
that he doesn't have to say these these
words out of himself like these exact
words but we should see the nature of
God we should see some some attributes
of God
Jes some not
some he okay okay
I please please wait wait please wait
let him finish let him finish please
please let him finish so so Versa if we
see some attributes within Jesus that
are Divine attributes that he shows
proof that he himself has the same
Divine attributes as God that would show
that he is God right
no I will not take it that way it will
it will be combined combined with what
he says equivocally combination of that
what he says and what he does is as a
sensible person that's what I will focus
on what he's telling me what he's
showing the people some are taking
it misunderstanding it and taking it
another way around so me now in this
generation now with you talking bringing
me these topics I will be very sensible
in what I observe as a a person carrying
a de de on Earth I will yes because
God have spoken to people for
Generations centuries so if it comes to
me now you bring me this message I will
ask you because I know God to not die I
know that God does not uh Sleep God is
Not does not get tired you know so these
are these are some of the qualities of
God that I expect to see from a God if
you say Jesus is God if you cannot show
me this in his action he should say
it yes I don't I'm a God but I uh I do
sleep oh but he's telling you there's
one God only one true true God you
you're not you're not dealing with
you're not dealing with it earlier you
said you gotta M you got to mute up you
got an
echo one
minute earlier you said because I asked
you if Jesus doesn't say the words
I and the father have the same nature
does that mean that it's not
scripturally true you said no but what I
would because what I would expect is to
see some of the characteristics or
Divine attributes of God in him to for
him to display the Divine attributes of
God that's what I liked what you said
because Jesus wouldn't have to say a
word but if he showed that he was God If
he if he displayed his Divine attributes
then you can clearly see that he's God
so he wouldn't have to even if he never
said it if he showed it to you that he's
doing things that only God
does claiming things that only God
claims he's proving to you that he's God
by his works but he has words and he has
works that back him up my friend but now
it seems like changing speaks through go
he said he's doing things through God's
finger the Finger by the power of God
he's telling you my
friend prophet Isaiah SP when he was
speaking to the Jews and telling them i
h i I am God and something like that I
am God he's speaking he him he as a
human is speaking saying I am God God he
he says thus says the
Lord is Isiah hold you misquoted Isaiah
Isaiah starts off with this is what the
Lord says and then he starts quoting God
Jesus doesn't do that he doesn't say
this is what the Lord says or this is
what my father says he says I say to you
every time Isaiah didn't have to say
Isaiah said it every time Isaiah said it
every
[Music]
time point of coration point of
coration so um let me let me just ask
you this uh versatile who's the one who
gives eternal life huh who's the one who
gives eternal life eternal life life
mhm from my my my perspective of
understanding eternal life is not it's
not like like maybe giving somebody you
know eternal life physically here on
Earth but eternal life in the
Hereafter next EXA exact let meish I
don't finish my answer please and that
is the way the way I so you somebody can
give me eternal life
like Jesus can give me eternal life here
understand it who is the one who gives
eternal life only God gives eternal life
beautiful thank you see that's all you
had to say yes so Jesus says that he
gives eternal life uhuh so if he says
that he gives eternal life it's only God
that gives eternal
life I'll give it to you I'll give it to
you I'll give it to you y If Only God
gives eternal life and Jesus says that
he gives eternal life who is Jesus
claiming to be no no no I will not
comment on that first give me the
context I'm dealing with no you have to
brighten the foundation on which I stand
to understand what I'm dealing with the
foundation of what you stand is the
concept of God you know that only God
gives
Eternal for example Jesus is speaking
please let me just ask you this
destination where you want me to go just
want you to be honest the destination I
want you to is truth that's that's where
I want you at it's just truth that's it
it's honesty if Jesus says that he gives
eternal life and only God gives eternal
life who does that make
Jesus you know what what I mean by make
my Foundation a little bit wide is
because the information where you giving
me the information from is skepticism
too much skepticism there from so I want
to
know know
know okay out of that what you are
giving me is what you what are you what
you given me to deal with is it from the
man himself exactly you know it's what I
want to understand you tell I'll show
I'll show you that in a second just
answer that that he gives eternal life
and only God gives eternal life who does
that make
Jesus okay the answer to your
your your question the situation I will
lay to you is Jesus said that because he
brought the message of God and if you
listen to that message of God as he is
telling the Jews that the sheep and the
shepher the Sheep knows their the
shepher the shepher knows the Sheep you
know they know his word you know the Jew
should understand the word of God that's
what he meaning if you understand the
word of God you listen to me and
understand that I'm a man of God I come
with a message of God you will
you will be saved if you die let me ask
you this did Muhammad come with the word
of God that is what is the eternal life
he's tell did mhamad come with the
message of God listen to me you do what
I'm telling
you you will get eternal
life versatile
versatile did Muhammad come with the
message of God yes does Muhammad give
you eternal
life God
he just said that he just said Muhammad
gives you guys eternal life do you guys
agree with he does have to say he does
have to
mus you say my name I'm G to show up on
the
screen
Jesus
Jesus wait Jesus Jesus Jesus clearly
said that the word he spoke are the
eternal life and Jesus made
aesus brother brother please mute
yourself please mute yourself brother
please mute yourself mute yourself let
the okay Jesus Jesus Jesus clearly said
that the work the words he spoke are not
his his his words but it is the father
who who like who like any word that he
speaks it is the the permission of the
father he doesn't speak without the
permission of the father and every every
everybody knows that the word he speak
belong to the father and he clearly said
that the words he spoke are the eternal
life so Jesus Christ himself is not the
eternal life but the word he spokes are
the eternal
life okay does Muhammad give you eternal
Live host no wait do you agree do you do
you agree with this do you agree with
this or you don't agree I don't agree
and I'mma show I'm showing you why so
you said you said muhamad doesn't give
etal life wait wait wait
come we are not yet
there go logic go logic I
know is okay I know your is that's where
what is my what is my tactic I know your
T I know your T that's what my tactic to
hold to hold you guys account
listen of Jesus Christ is the eternal
life not Jesus Christ himself eternal
life Jes Jesus Jesus literally says
listen you are you are trying to make
the people understand that Jesus Christ
himself can grant you eternal life
meanwhile Jesus CHR wait wait wait Jesus
Christ himself said that
can he do it or
not what is going on here there's so
many people talking can Muhammad give
eternal life or
not versatile says yes the host says no
I'm confused I I didn't say no I didn't
say
no I didn't answer you I didn't answer
you I didn't answer you I didn't you I
was talking I was talking about I was
talking about you say can't do that I I
didn't say
no you have to answer the other
question man I love you guys man you
guys are awesome
godic God
God said no versatile said yes they know
I said they know I said it's not talking
about the question that you asked me I
said no wait let me ask you host can mam
give eternal life
brother yes he give eternal life you
changed your answer then listen listen
listen listen he etal life he etal
life not concentrating on him you guys
show me the ver that says mamed gives
you eternal
life you guys just left Islam congrat